brought to you by The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt available now hey guys my name is
Justin McDonald today it's the 19th of
May and your change into games what
games Xbox boss Phil Spencer is once
again said that the company has no plans
to ditch the Kinect even though the
device is optional to the Xbox one
experience Spencer told edge via
GamesRadar quote it's not abandoned
saying that Microsoft will continue to
make the device a valuable part of the
Xbox ecosystem he explained that the
company decided to offer Xbox ones
without Kinect to give consumers a
better price point and another
alternative currently Kinect free Xbox
one bundles start at 350 bucks while
those including the camera are $500 as
for how much we can expect to see the
Kinect integrated into Xbox one and its
upcoming titles Spencer explains there
are John Roos where connect works really
well but if you're playing Halo or Call
of Duty there's not really a scenario
that says hey I need a Kinect Tice have
already confirmed that Star Wars
Battlefront
is going to run at 60 frames per second
but today EA have come out to say that
nothing has been confirmed for the
resolution on a Q&A post on Reddit EAS
community manager reply to a post
suggesting the game could be 720p or 900
P by saying no one said anything about
resolution this wasn't the only tidbit
of information drops though they said
that PC requirements are still yet to be
determined at this testing stage but
also that ebooks are 100% on indoor it's
also been clarified that there are 12
multiplayer maps turtle and additional
mission maps all of which will offer
various environments and locations
finally porn is unsurprisingly a thing
on the oculus rift but today oculus VR
found that Palmer Luckey has come out to
say he's cool with it lucky has
confirmed that Adult Entertainment
weren't be prohibited from appearing on
the device after Silicon Valley VR
conference he said quote the rift
and open platform we don't control what
software can run on it and that's a big
deal the oculus rift consumer model will
launch at the beginning of next year and
pricing is yet to be announced
let me know down in the comments if you
think Xbox one is better with or without
Kinect and why you can add to gain spot
where we've got you on NHL 16 and some
God of War 3 remastered gameplay that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today let me know what you care about
and uh catch you same time tomorrow